what's going on everybody it's warren
and welcome back to the cosmic wonder
where we talk all things marvel and
mcu and we are less than 12 hours away
from
the finale of wanda vision and this
morning we actually got some pretty big
reveals
about one division about what to expect
from the finale including that secret
cameo that paul bettany was talking
about
and some news that might actually
confirm some plot leaks for the finale
of one division which of course we're
going to talk about and break down in
this video
now these leaks are theories that i've
been talking about for quite some time
now but if you are trying to avoid any
and all spoilers you should probably
click away now
if you're still with me you're probably
aware that at one point in time during
an
interview paul bettany teased a surprise
secret cameo coming to wanda vision
he teased that it's an actor that he
always wanted to work with
he teased that they had great chemistry
together on set
and of course we all went crazy trying
to figure out just exactly who the
secret cameo was going to be
is it going to be patrick stewart ian
mckellen michael fassbender
could it be somebody like mephisto or
nightmare
well this morning on good morning
america paul bettany has seemingly
answered this question
however i'm not sure we should take him
seriously
but this is what he had to say this
morning yeah you know when he thinks
something's gonna be funny and you say
it and then you
actually panic about it which is what i
did because
fans started guessing who it might be
and they were getting
people like benedict cumberbatch or
patrick stewart and i was thinking
god that's a good idea and they're going
to be so disappointed when they find out
it's me
but we're not sure though you could be
trolling us right now so is there
a big appearance by someone well you
know i'd love to answer that question
but my
uh my service kids so when white vision
popped up at the end of
one division episode 8 everybody
immediately thought
wow paul bettany was actually talking
about himself he is the actor
that he has always wanted to work with
he was simply making a big joke out of
it and according to him that actually
seems to be
what was happening he was trying to make
a joke but it got a little out of hand
however he could simply be trolling us
right now and there could actually be a
cameo because
when elizabeth olson was doing an
interview she was asked if we should
expect a big cameo on the level of luke
skywalker and she replied with
yes but was she also talking about paul
bettany because she knew what he said
and she was playing along
that is very well a possibility and i
think that's what we should expect
going into the one division finale so we
are not upset if there
is no secret cameo then if there is a
secret cameo it'll end up just being a
great surprise for everybody
but with paul bettany admitting that
it's actually himself that he was
talking about this actually points to
a leak about the finale getting more
true and it looks like the big finale is
going to be pretty much what everything
has built up towards and what we've all
been expecting all along and there's
more things that point to this being
true that we got in some previous
episodes as well for starters
it says that quicksilver evan peters is
not
from the fox universe but he is indeed
quicksilver
the leaker said that it will indeed be
explained later
it also says that there is no secret
cameo of magneto professor x or reed
richards
now of course we all started to think
about these characters possibly entering
the mcu
in one division because of what paul
bettany said but seeing as how he
debunked that this morning on good
morning america and is most likely
telling the truth it would make sense
that these characters wouldn't show up
however somebody like reed richards
could have been the aerospace engineer
but it appears like we've already seen
the aerospace engineer
yesterday director matt shakman opened
up about all of the theories surrounding
who the aerospace engineer was going to
be
and he pretty much confirmed that the
aerospace engineer isn't going to be
anybody like reed richards
hank mccoy blue marvel nobody like that
and he actually pretty much confirmed
that we've already met the aerospace
engineer and that person was indeed
major goodner however this leak takes it
a bit further and says that the
aerospace engineer is actually a scroll
and it says that this will actually tie
directly into captain marvel 2
and the secret invasion disney plus
story and this would make a lot of sense
because of course monica rambo
knows scrolls and she personally knows
captain marvel
and now she's going to be a superhero
she's going to come out of one division
with
super power she's going to become the
hero spectrum or photon depending on
which name she takes on
and given her connection to captain
marvel it would just make sense that she
would show up in captain marvel 2 and of
course secret invasion
because of her relationship with the
scroll now here's where something gets
pretty interesting and it's actually
something that i've been kind of saying
for a little bit now
if you've joined me for my one division
watch parties and the discussions after
we've been talking a
long time since the very beginning about
agatha's rabbit
mr scratchy and this leak says that
agatha's rabbit mr scratchy is somebody
very cool and bad they say that this
will be teased at the end and go into
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness now i firmly believe that her
rabbit
is indeed somebody she was talking to
the rabbit in the last episode and since
they really put emphasis on it at some
points in time i've just really felt
like it actually is somebody
i do believe there is a bigger villain
behind agatha hartness and that villain
will indeed
show itself eventually now there has
been a rumor going around that mark
hamill could indeed be the rabbit
playing nightmare this would be
insanely awesome and i have stated my
case for how nightmare would be a very
perfect villain for one division and
then
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness but for right now that is simply
a rumor we'll have to see how that plays
out the leak
goes on to say that hex vision versus
spectral vision or the vision that wanda
created versus the vision that is
somewhat
ultron that hayward created is a thing
and of course it's a thing obviously
hayward's vision is going to attack
wanda's vision and not only wanda's
vision but wanda and her twin voice
herself and it's going to be up to her
and vision to defeat this one along with
agatha harkness but this leak says that
there is going to be no
fusing together between the two visions
meaning they are not going to combine
and become
one true real vision because there was a
theory going around for a while which
was actually a pretty good theory
stating that the vision that wanda
created was sort of
vision soul and then the vision that
hayward created was his actual body made
out of vibranium and the theory was that
the two of them would actually fuse
together at the end to create the vision
that we knew
from age of ultron but the leak says
that it won't happen so we'll have to
see how that plays out the leak goes on
to say that the battle scenes in the end
are
insane and cgi is on par with avengers
in game
everybody has their moment at the end
now this is something that we actually
kind of already knew in an interview
paul bettany talked about the finale of
one division and how there's going to be
a big fight and how they're going to use
more cgi
than they used in avengers in game and
if you think about it we have
witch versus witch so there's going to
be a lot of magic involved in this
two visions going at it a version of
quicksilver
monaco rambo with her new super powers
and then of course the twin boys who
have powers of their own super speed and
magical abilities you're putting all of
these characters together with all these
powers in one
final fight of course the cgi is going
to be absolutely insane and i can't wait
to see it
now this leak does say that it's going
to be very sad but very fulfilling and
we've been wondering for the longest
time if the twins and vision are going
to actually be able to survive
once the hex is gone it seemed very
clear a few episodes ago that
vision the one that wanda created could
not survive outside of the hex
but will this be true at the end and is
this true for the boys even though she
actually gave birth to them
now the final thing that this leak says
is that doctor strange is going to show
up at the end at a very precise moment
that makes sense now this could be
during the final battle
after the final battle or it could even
be in the post credit scene it doesn't
specify
but considering the fact that this leads
up to doctor strange and the multiverse
of madness it would make sense that he
would make an appearance at some point
and since his job is protecting our
reality he's probably going to sense all
of this magical energy flying around
at the end during the final battle and
even though he's not exactly close with
wanda of course he knows who she is
because of infinity war and
endgame and what i'm assuming is going
to happen is that at the end he's going
to take her under his wing
and train her possibly to protect her
from a certain villain that could be
coming mr scratchy or
nightmare or as i've actually been
stating over the past week
c'thun the evil elder god who could go
on to be the villain of doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness
but that is it for this final leak and
the theory surrounding what
exactly is going to happen tonight in
the final episode of wanda
vision this is your last chance to put
in the comments down below
what you think is going to happen in the
grand finale and of course i will be
doing my watch party tonight it starts
at 2 50 a.m
eastern time and then of course we'll be
doing our discussion after hope to see a
lot of you there
and of course if you love marvel be sure
to subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the future videos
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof